>> Gutfeld: YES!
ALL RIGHT!
WHERE MY?
HERE I AM.
HAPPY TUESDAY EVERYONE.
WHAT A GLORIOUS NIGHT FOR NEWS.
AND YES, YOU'RE STILL A
TERRORIST.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF
YOU'RE ASSEMBLING A PIPE BOMB
RIGHT NOW JUST REMOVE YOU FROM
THIS MISERY.
♪ ♪
>> I'VE SEEN FIRE AND I'VE SEEN
RAIN.
I'VE SEEN SUNNY DAYS AND I
THOUGHT THEY'D NEVER END.
♪ ♪
>> Gutfeld: THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TIMES WHEN I ENVY MARLEE
MATLIN SORT OF THE ACTUAL
TERRORISTS ARE SMART FUNNY
STORY.
AFTER 21 YEARS, WHICH IS ROUGHLY
HOW LONG IT TAKES THE PRESIDENT
TO, IT APPEARS THE PENTAGON IS
OPEN TO THE PLEA DEAL WITH THE
FIVE MASTERMINDS BEHIND 9/11 IN
EXCHANGE FOR A FOR LIFE
SENTENCES THE FIVE WILL DROP ALL
APPEALS AND AGREED TO
SUBSTANTIAL SENTENCES IN
AMERICAN PRISONS.
OR THEY GET TO CHOOSE WHAT'S
BEHIND DOOR NUMBER TWO.
>> YOU TURNED DOWN...
>> Gutfeld: THAT'S WHAT
AL QAEDA CALLS A COUPLE OF
BODIES.
AND EVEN BETTER, THEY ARE.
AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT THEY
CLAIMED ON GOAT TINDER.
BUT WHAT TIMING.
THEY'RE MAKING DEALS WITH THE
9/11 HIJACKERS WHEN WE KNEW WE
WOULD BE DISTRACTED WITH 9/11
RATED AND THEN THE HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IS CREATING NEW TERRORISTS USING
THE 21ST ANNIVERSARY TO A GREAT
AMERICAN'S WITH THE HIJACKERS.
>> THE THREAT LANDSCAPE HAS
EVOLVED CONSIDERABLY OVER THE
LAST 20 YEARS.
WE ARE SEEING AN EMERGING THREAT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENT EXTREMIST
IDEOLOGY OF HATE, ANTIGOVERNMENT
SENTIMENT, FALSE NARRATIVES
PROPAGATED ON ONLINE PLATFORMS,
EVEN PERSONAL GRIEVANCES.
>> Gutfeld: EVEN PERSONAL
GRIEVANCES ON LIES!
DO YOU SEE WHAT THIS NOT BUCKET
JUST DID?
HE EQUATES THE 9/11 ATTACK WITH
ONLINE LIES AND PERSONAL
GRIEVANCES.
AS YOU KNOW THAT'S 98.9% OF THE
CONTENT THAT APPEARS ONLINE.
TALK ABOUT INFLATION.
TERRORISM JUST WENT FROM LOCKING
DOWN THE TWIN TOWERS TO LEAVING
A MEAN MESSAGE ON YELP.
I HAVEN'T SEEN AN EXAGGERATION
LIKE THAT SINCE BRIAN WILLIAMS
AND HILLARY CLINTON WHERE IN THE
SPECIAL FORCES.
PERSONAL GRIEVANCES IS NO AN
EMERGING THREAT ON PAR WITH
AL QAEDA.
TERRORISM, IT'S NOT JUST FOR
TERRORISTS ANYMORE.
NOW IT'S FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE MAD
THEY DIDN'T GET THE SENIOR
DISCOUNT AT DENNY'S.
KEY DEMO.
BETTER THINK TWICE BEFORE YOU
CALL TO COMPLAIN ABOUT YOUR
NEIGHBORS.
BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF THE SAME
SPECTRUM OF BEHAVIOR, ESPECIALLY
IF YOU'RE NEIGHBOR HAS A BIDEN
BUMPER STICKER ON HIS PREVIOUS.
YOU CAN END UP ON A TERRORIST
WATCH LIST ARE ON THE WRONG END
OF A BOMB.
>> HELLO SIR.
ANY CARRY-ONS.
>> JUST MY DYNAMITE.
>> DO YOU PROMISE NOT TO TAKE
HIM ON THE PLANE?
>> SURE.
>> SECURITY!
TERRACE TICKET NINE.
>> I'M THE TERRORIST HERE.
YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO GET
DYNAMITE WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
WATCH LIST.
>> PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEAT.
>> HOW ABOUT A DRINK VOUCHER?
>> I'M ON ANTIBIOTICS.
>> IT'S A DAIQUIRI.
>> IN THAT CASE I'LL TAKE TWO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OF COURSE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Gutfeld: VERY NICE.
MAYBE I'M EXAGGERATING WHICH
I'VE DONE A MILLION TIMES, A
LITTLE HUMOR THERE.
BUT YOU SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT?
WHEN THIS HAD ITS STOMACH SAYS
THE THREAT LANDSCAPE HAS
EVOLVED, HE'S REALLY SAYING
WE'VE GONE AHEAD AND WIDENED IT.
AND THAT'S NORMAL IF YOU'RE
BRIAN STELTER'S TAYLOR AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HIS PANTS.
BUT THIS IS TO STOKE FEAR AHEAD
OF THE MIDTERMS.
THIS JERK IS PUTTING ALL THESE
ACTIVITIES UNDER THE SAME
UMBRELLA.
AN INSULT ON TWITTER CAN BE A
STEPPING STONE TO FLYING A PLANE
INTO A BUILDING.
BUT LIKE THE PRESIDENT'S DROOL,
THIS KIND OF THREAT ONLY FLOWS
ONE WAY.
THEY DON'T MIND RHETORIC WHEN
IT'S COMING FROM UNHINGED
LIBERALS OR EVEN VIOLENCE.
THE GUY WHO KILLED THE LAS VEGAS
JOURNALIST IS STILL ON THE
PAYROLL.
KAREN BASS, DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
FOR L.A. MAYOR, LOST A PAIR OF
GUNS, NOTHING TO SEE THERE.
TO THE DHS THAT WAS JUST A BAD
HAIR DAY.
THE VICTIM SHOULD'VE CALLED A
SOCIAL WORKER BUT YOU'RE WORSE
THAN ALL THEM BECAUSE OF YOUR
BELIEFS.
NOW YOU'RE WORSE THAN AL QAEDA.
STARTING TO THINK MAYBE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE GIVEN THE
GOVERNMENT THESE POWERS TO FIGHT
TERRORISM IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THESE HIM AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
AND ANOTHER USING USING THEM ON
US.
REMEMBER THIS IS THE SAME GUY
WHO ALLOWED TRAGIC FLOW OF
DROWNINGS BECAUSE OF BORDER
PATROL.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK THAT THIS
ASSET IS EMPLOYED TO MAKE, WILL
LOOK COMPETENT.
IT'S NOT WORKING, BUT ANYWAY.
UNDER HIS WATCH WE'VE SEEN THE
AMERICANS DIED BY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS FROM FENTON OLD THAT'S
COMING THE BORDER.
THAT WEAKENS THE DOMESTIC THREAT
OR MAYBE THAT'S HIS WAY OF
WINNING THE WAR ON DRUGS, LET
THE USERS DIE.
BUT IF WE DID THE NUMBERS IN
TERMS OF AMERICAN DOUBTS?
THAT WOULD MAKE US MANY TIMES
WORSE THAN NO STOMACH AL QAEDA.
A COUPLE OF THOUSAND VICTIMS
EVERY DAY.
YOU CALL THAT HOMELAND SECURITY,
YOU POINTY EARED CHROME DOMED
GREMLIN?
WHAT HE'S DOING IS A HUNDRED
TIMES WORSE THAN JANUARY 6, BUT
WE GET IT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
ISSUED 40 SUBPOENAS THIS WEEK IN
CONNECTION WITH JANUARY 6 AND
EFFORTS OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
LIKE A FORT THROUGH AN END 95
MASK THEIR COMING OVER THE
BORDER.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I KNOW THAT.
WHICH SETS THE STAGE FOR MORE
JANUARY 6 HEARINGS, WHICH THE
MEDIUM BRACES FOR EDSON
DISTRACTING POWER.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO REAL
ISSUES, DEMOCRATS SUCK, CRIME,
THE BORDER, THEY GOT NOTHING TO
RUN ON.
EXCEPT FOR YOU.
THE GOING TO RUN A NEW.
YOU'RE THE ISSUE.
YOU'RE THE PROBLEM.
AND SO THE HUNT IS ON.
IN THE GOOD OLD DAYS THE BAD GUY
WOULD BE A TERRACE HIJACKER
ANNOUNCED TO SOMEONE IN THE RED
HAT.
BUT I GUESS IT'S EASIER THAN
HAVING THE FBI PLAYING
KIDNAPPINGS.
HE DIE SETS CORPORATE CULTURE,
HE'S HERE!
HIS FAVORITE DATING SHOWS
FORENSIC FILES.
AND JIM NORTON LIKE A HANDFUL OF
KETTLE CORN SHE'S SWEET AND
SALTY AND CAN BE FOUND ON THE
FLOOR OF THE THEATER, FOXES
CONTRIBUTOR!
FINALLY, HIS OPTOMETRIST NEEDS
SCAFFOLDING.
MY SIDEKICK!
JIM, ARE YOU A TERRORIST?
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE TO PROVE ME
WRONG.
>> THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT.
I TAKE OFF MY CLOTHES AND I
FRIGHTEN PEOPLE OUT OF THE ROOM.
DOMESTIC TERRORISM, ALL RIGHT,
IT'S GOT TO BE ADDRESSED.
BUT LET'S HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION.
I'D RATHER HAVE MY PILOT SAY
LET'S GO BRANDON THEN ALI AKBAR.
>> Gutfeld: THAT DESERVES
APPLAUSE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Gutfeld: ARE YOU GUYS
ASLEEP OUT THERE?
>> USUALLY THINGS COME IN FOR
THREES.
>> BOY, DO I KNOW THAT.
>> Gutfeld: WHAT YOU MAKE OF
THE PERFORMANCE ON 9/11, IT
SEEMS WRONG TO ME.
>> IT'S LIKE A 20 A GAME OF
PING-PONG STOMACH PUNK BECAUSE
WE DID SOME NASTY THINGS ON THE
BACK OF 9/11.
THAT WAS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
THEY CREATED A SURVEILLANCE
STATE.
NOW ANOTHER BUNCH OF PEOPLE HAS
USED IT AGAINST OUR POLITICAL
ENEMIES AT HOME.
COULD BE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
USING IT AGAIN IN EIGHT OR TEN
YEARS BUT THAT'S THE GAME OR
PLAYING.
>> Gutfeld: I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, THE REPUBLICANS GET
POWER AND SO WERE GOING TO DO IT
TO THEM.
>> THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
>> Gutfeld: I WAS BEING
IRONIC, YOU AUDIENCE PEOPLE!
IT'S LIKE SAYING I WAS FOR THE
PATRIOT ACT BEFORE BUT NOW IT'S
AGAINST ME AND SO I DON'T LIKE
IT ANYMORE.
IT'S TRUE.
>> TURN THE TABLES, IF YOU FEEL
DIFFERENTLY, IT MEANS YOU NOT
FOLLOWING PRINCIPLES.
>> Gutfeld: IS MALLORCA'S
INSPIRING VIOLENCE AGAINST TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S AND IS MY RAISING
THE ISSUE DOES THAT BRING
VIOLENCE OR THE THREAT OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST HIM?
>> IT COULD BE FOR ANY CRAZY
REASON TO DO A VIOLENT THING.
AGAIN I THINK YOU'RE COMPLETELY
RIGHT THAT WE SHOULD NEVER HAVE
GIVEN THE GOVERNMENT THOSE
POWERS.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO GET RID OF
THEM, WHETHER IT'S SURVEILLANCE
OR THE TSA.
I HATE FLYING BECAUSE THE TSA.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE LIKE,
THAT'S BECAUSE YOUR BAG IS FULL
OF DRUGS.
THAT WOULD BE ORIGINAL.
BUT IT'S JUST THAT EVERY
SITUATION WHERE THE SCENARIO IS,
YOU HAVE TO LET ME GRAB YOUR AND
I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU WHY,
THAT'S GONNA MAKE ME
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Gutfeld: IT'S TRUE THAT WE
ALLOWED TERRORISM ALLOW
STRANGERS TO TOUCH US IN PUBLIC.
>> WHY ARE YOU GRABBING ME
THERE?
>> PEOPLE ACTUALLY GRAB YOU?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Gutfeld: WHEN MY MOM WAS
FLYING, SHE WAS IN HER 80s,
SHE PULLED UP HER SHIRT.
IT WAS HUMILIATING.
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT?
>> MAYBE THEY WERE JUST SAYING,
HAVE A GOOD DAY.
I HAVE TO KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR
THAT.
YOU KNOW, HE MAKES A GREAT POINT
ABOUT THE PATRIOT ACT, NO IT'S
AN ACT AGAINST THE PATRIOTS.
IT'S COME FULL CIRCLE.
THEY MADE THE BAR SO LOW THAT
THE NEVER WRONG.
IF YOU SAY, OH, MAN, I DON'T
LIKE SLEEPY JOE.
YOU'RE A TERRORIST.
THE BAR IS NOT LOW.
WHEN SOMETHING HORRIBLE HAPPENS,
TODAY I SAW A STAT ABOUT 500,000
GETAWAYS THIS FISCAL YEAR.
YOU DON'T THINK A FEW OF THEM
ARE MILITARY TRAINED?
ARE COMING FROM PLACES WHO
SHOULDN'T BE THERE CHRIS MUDGE
BUT WHERE TARGETING PEOPLE WITH
THE RED HAT SAYING AMERICA NEEDS
TO BE GREAT A BIT AGAIN.
THAT'S THE ENEMY.
HE'LL BE HAPPY TO TELL YOU WHAT
HIS BELIEFS ARE BUT HE'S THE GUY
YOU HAVE TO WATCH OUT FOR?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WE GET HIT WITH SOMETHING, THEN,
YOU KNOW...
[APPLAUSE]
>> Gutfeld: IT'S ALSO LIKE
THIS EVER-EXPANDING TARGET.
LET'S SAY THE TARGET IS TRUMP
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH
TRUMP, IF YOU'RE FRIENDS WITH
THEM, IF YOU EVER TALK TO
SOMEBODY, THEY COULD CALL YOU
AND SAY WE HAVE A PHONE CALL
WITH YOU AND SOMEBODY ELSE.
THAT'S THE GAME.
SEE ONE END UP WORKING FOR TRUMP
OR ANYBODY IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE
YOU'LL BE TOO TERRIFIED.
>> ALSO THE EXPANSION OF
LANGUAGE.
THEY'RE DOING IT WITH RACISM AND
TERRORISM.